jetzt kommen wir mal zu den echten
Problemen des Landes mein persönlicher
Aufreger des Tages und ähm somit auch
die Frage ob auch Männer Kinder bekommen
können ja tatsächlich ist diese Frage
gerade eine Buch für Kinder frisch
verarbeitet worden mit einer
Ernsthaftigkeit die mich persönlich
wirklich Erstaunen lassen ich war auf
der Suche nach einem nach einem Buch für
meinen kleinen Neffen der bereits ein
zweites Brüderchen bekommt und ja dann
bin ich bei Amazon auf dieses ich hoffe
es wird gleich noch eingeblendet ähm ich
zitiere Papi hast du ein Baby im Bauch
so das ist dieses Buch wir sehen es hier
jetzt ist eingeblendet ich bin fast vom
Sessel geflogen das Problem ist dass
dieses Buch eben nur exemplarisch für
einen Teil für einen Trend in unserer
Gesellschaft steht der im Ordnung und
Werte so wie wir sie können abschaffen
möchte so und während diese
Ordnungsprinzipien ich nenne sie jetzt
mal so in unserer Gesellschaft immer
weiter erodieren und wir uns nur noch
mit scheinen Problemen beschäftigen
überrollen uns die echten und zwar
sinnflutartig müssen wir nicht dringend
mal unser Bildungssystem dran ich habe
es eben angesprochen wir haben
Migrationsdruck wir haben Kostendruck
unsere Sozialsysteme Gewalt Kriminalität
und so weiter all das fängt bei der
Bildung an ist die Grundlage für alles
und stattdessen dass wir mal uns mit
diesen Dingen beschäftigen werden
unseren Kindern umerziehungsbücher und
unerfahren um erziehungsphantasien
Kredenz präsentiert schön mit Bildern
aufbereitet ich frage mich wirklich
warum müssen wir unseren Kindern immer
Angst machen es fängt in der Schule an
es fängt mit Schulmaterialien an er geh
mal in unseren Kindermusical rein
beispielsweise das endet immer mit dabei
immer mit dem Appell daran man soll
Energie sparen warum müssen warum muss
das bei Kindern muss immer darauf achten
ist wirklich dann haben wir jetzt äh äh
queer Pride man steht jetzt vor der Tür
das kennen die Kinder alle ich war aber
ganz stark zu bezweifeln dass
irgendeiner von den weiß wann Pfingsten
ist was Pfingsten ist und was das Ganze
überhaupt soll
ich glaube dass wir hier völlig falsch
justiert sind in Deutschland wird immer
irre wenn ich persönlich jetzt Kinder
hätte die würden überhaupt gar keine
normale Schule mehr gehen die würde ich
einpacken würdest du irgendein
katholisches Internat packen am besten
nach Bayern oder sonst wohin wo die Welt
noch in Ordnung ist und ansonsten kann
ich nur hoffen dass wir diesen Trend
Einheit Gebieten weil wir sind immer
noch in der absolut Mehrheit es gibt
vielleicht ein Prozent der Bevölkerung
die das nicht hochgradig irre finden
also das war jetzt ein ganz schön großes
Paket ich muss einmal sagen meine Kinder
gehen eine ganz normale Schule in Berlin
da ist die Welt auch noch in Ordnung
aber klar wir wollen das einmal hier
öffnen hier war zumindest auch wir haben
angefangen mit dem Buch das ähm Frau
Bosbach gezeigt hat Frau Kelle war das
für sie quasi ein exemplarisches
Beispiel wo im Thema
selbstbestimmungsgesetz etwas schief
läuft wer sang es mir so man muss die
Dinge ein bisschen voneinander trennen
also ich frage mich ja immer ob solche
Bücher überhaupt gekauft werden also
diese diese diese neuen Bücher die da
entstehen die werden zwar angepriesen
das Problem ist dass die teilweise jetzt
inzwischen in Kindergärten und in
Schulen als Schulmaterial an empfohlen
werden
und dort quasi wir jetzt anfangen und
das ist das neue hier in dieser Politik
und da gehört diese
selbstbestimmungsgesetz dass die
Regierung jetzt auch gerne am liebsten
noch vor dem Sommer reinbekommen will
wir haben jetzt eine Politik die sich
von Fakten verabschiedet also die jetzt
so weit in ihrer Ideologie geht dass sie
bereit ist einerseits immer zu schreien
follow the science und gleichzeitig
Naturwissenschaften in die Tonne klopft
und sagt irgendwie die Ideologie und die
Selbstbestimmung geht so weit dass wir
uns von unserem Körper verabschieden
können und jeder definiert jetzt selber
sein Geschlecht und wir machen jetzt ein
Gesetz das sogar Kindern das ermöglichen
soll in Zweifel sogar gegen den Willen
ihrer Eltern und im Zweifel wenn Sie als
Eltern nicht mitziehen wenn sie mal die
Details sich angucken in diesem
Gesetzentwurf dann kann es darauf
hinauslaufen dass Sie als Eltern sogar
das Sorgerecht verlieren für ihre Kinder
wenn sie dann nämlich nicht mitziehen
und da fängt das jetzt an gefährlich zu
werden und deswegen muss dieses Gesetz
verhindert werden weil es kommt im
Übrigen nicht nur ein Gesetz dass völlig
absurd jedem Bundesbürger einmal im Jahr
die Möglichkeit gibt sein Geschlecht zu
ändern ja also man möge sich mal
vorstellen was das eigentlich für einen
Irrsinn auslösen kann sondern diese
Regierung will sogar unter Strafe
stellen dass wir die Wahrheit noch
aussprechen also wenn du Patricia jetzt
sagst ich bin jetzt der Horst und wir
hier in die Sendung kommen und dich mit
Patricia weiterhin ansprechen dann
kostet das dann mit diesem Gesetz 10.000
€, wenn du nach einem Jahr beschließt
ich bin wieder Patricia müssen wir dich
sogar wieder Patricia nennen sonst
kostet das wieder 10000 €, das ist
unsere Bundesregierung man man zweifelt
langsam am restverstand einfach von
ganzen Ministerien dass man so halt so
etwas überhaupt sagt in die
Öffentlichkeit zu geben und was man
nicht vergessen darf es ist eine riesen
Gefahr für Frauen es ist eine Gefahr für
Frauen und für Kinder und wir sind
wieder in der in der Emanzipation
gefallen sie erlauben nämlich jetzt
wieder Männern zu definieren was eine
Frau ist mit Verlaub Frau sein ist kein
Gefühlszustand den jeder annehmen kann
sondern ich bin auch keine zisfrau ich
bin eine Frau ich muss gar keinen Zusatz
haben ich bin ich bin quasi von Natur
aus Frau und muss das gar nicht beweisen
als Sprecher für Toleranz müssen wir bei
diesem Thema ein bisschen mehr runter
kochen Sie hier machen sich ja auch
viele Menschen die von dieser
schwierigen Entscheidung sind diese
Entscheidung nicht unbedingt einfach
also ich finde erstmal dass es ganz gut
dass Frauen hier die Deutung so halt
darüber haben wollen was Frauen eben
sind und ich finde das absolut richtig
und ich finde und ich finde ich als Mann
kann da nur staunen auch über diese
Entwicklung heutzutage her aber ich
finde es wichtig dass jeder sage ich mal
die deutungswald da an sich herangezogen
wird das sage ich mal diese Entwicklung
zumindest an angesprochen werden und ja
sie die Zeit wird das zeigen ich finde
aber sowas gehört definitiv weder in die
Kindergärten noch nie Grundschule hinein
ich finde das ist sehr verwirrend glaube
ich auch ich meine ich habe selber zwei
Kinder und mein wir haben unsere Kinder
nicht in irgendwelche rollen Klischees
und irgendwelche spezielle Kleidung
gesteckt sondern können das einfach ganz
entspannt ja und genau ja also mein Sohn
der sagt von klein auf Junge und Mädchen
und es ist glaube ich ganz seltsam würde
das für ihn sein würde man jetzt ihn sag
mal ist es gibt ja diese Menschen okay
wunderbar aber warum soll man die jetzt
in diesem jungen Jahren damit
konfrontieren das kann man auch später
machen und dann sind sie auch gefestigt
da in ihre eigenen Persönlichkeit und
dann auch von mir aus aber dass da so
jetzt so wieder von oben das
raufzusetzen
Toleranz nicht so nee weil ich glaube es
ist ein riesen Fortschritt dass man in
Deutschland man kann schwul sein man
kann lesbisch sein man kann Leben wie
man will und das will ich immer aber mir
erzählen und Klauen verteidigen also das
war ist ein riesen Fortschritt dass das
heute geht aber dieses Gesetz und
überhaupt diese Debatte die rollt das ja
teilweise zurück ja also zum Beispiel
sie haben es ja angesprochen Frauen
Schutzräumen also es gibt ja durchaus
Bereiche wo Frauen aus guten Grund unter
sich sein immer wieder werden
Frauensauna auch Frauentoilette also ich
finde auch diese Euphorie für die
unisex-toilette also ich kenne von
Lehrern das Problem an Schulen wo die
die unisexoilette eingeführt haben die
Mädchen werden penetrant belästigt die
Mädchen trauen sich also jetzt nicht
mehr rein auf die Toilette so und das
ist wirklich zu nein ich werde definitiv
zustimmig ich halte es auch wirklich für
gefährlich weil nicht nur in dieser
Trend dabei ist sondern es gibt ja auch
wirklich und da wird es ganz ernst immer
mehr junge Leute ich meine der Pubertät
ist man erstmal so ein bisschen hat man
eine schwierige Phase und man legt den
jungen Leuten gerade zu nahe ihre
Probleme darin zu sehen dass sie im
falschen Körper sind und es gibt ja
immer mehr solche OPs und ich meine es
mag ein ganz kleinen Prozentsatz von
Menschen geben bei denen ist das
vielleicht angebracht und da soll das
auch möglich sein und das soll keine
Geldfrage sein aber indem man tausenden
jungen Frauen also sind vor allem Frauen
na liegt ach sie sind doch vielleicht in
falschen Geschlecht und sie lassen sich
umoperieren nicht mal andere Länder
haben das schon früher so liberalisiert
wie wir das jetzt Vorhaben jetzt haben
die sich Klagen von dann etwas älteren
ehemaligen Frauen die diese Entscheidung
schwer bereuen die ist aber nicht
rückgängig also die Brüste
Verletzung wir reden hier richtig gut
alle Körperverletzung und Verstümmelung
und das bei ganz jungen Menschen die
dann irgendwann merken eigentlich wollen
sie diese Hormone nicht mehr schlucken
eigentlich waren sie doch im richtigen
Körper aber dann ist es zu spät